Speaker 1: Today. We welcome
to the program Melissa Peltier,
who's an award winning filmmaker and producer
of the documentary The Game Is Up. Disillusioned
Trump Voters Tell Their Stories. Melissa, really
great having you on. I appreciate your time.
Speaker 4: Thank you. I'm excited to be here.
Speaker 1: So, you know, we've seen and even done
interviews at Trump rallies with those who are
not disillusioned. In other words, they still are
Trump supporters. And it's interesting to ask them
why they have not abandoned Donald Trump, given
that, of course, just about every promise he made,
he didn't keep he made very clear that he only
even really cares about these folks to the extent
that they're useful to him, and then he no longer
cares, you know, all these things. So we've heard
from the people that are that are sticking with
him. You did something interesting, which is you
spoke to many disillusioned Trump voters to figure
out why are they no longer sort of part of the
cult as it may be? Was there one coherent story
about what ultimately drove them away, or was
it really different things for different people?
Speaker 4: It was different.
There were a couple of
people who had pinpointed Helsinki with Trump
and Putin as one trigger. But I mean, everyone
kind of mentioned that, I think, all along, but
everybody had a different reason because they all
had different reasons for voting for him.
Speaker 1: Oh, that's interesting. So in
other words, the reasons whatever originally
attracted them to Trump was a factor in what
ultimately dissuaded them.
Speaker 4: Exactly.
Speaker 1: Can can you give a couple examples?
Speaker 4: Well off the top of my head, our
farmer, Chris Gibbs, he was you know, he was kind
of laser focused on the agricultural aspect of it,
which is, you know, you have to remember that
people often vote just for their own personal
reasons, not just because their blanket
there are racist or their whatever. Yeah,
he was really laser focused on agriculture.
He liked the idea that Trump was going to
lift the waters of the US rule. He
he was just he didn't like Trump,
you know, like he wasn't in love with him, but he
voted for him because he did like Hillary. And he
also felt that Trump was really kind of anti anti
government on your property kind of thing. And so
he voted for him and he was impressed with some
of the things he did in the beginning. And then
he began to see what Trump's real agricultural
policy was doing. And really, the trade wars
just decimated the agriculture business,
and nobody knows that except the people who
are decimated. Only a few of them, I think with
Trump with like Chris had gone away from Trump,
but he was watching it very carefully. He had
actually worked for the Department of Agriculture
as a Farm Bill guy, and he just was disgusted with
it. And then he kept hearing Trump lie and lie
and lie like saying the China China's paying the
tariffs and he just broke it. Was it that was it.
Speaker 1: The tariffs
thing is interesting because
it doesn't really seem that Donald Trump has ever
understood how how tariffs work. And of course,
he insists China pays the tariffs. But really
what happens is the United States puts a tariff
on Chinese imports. And so whoever is buying the
Chinese imports still pays China for the stuff,
but then also pays a tariff to the United States
government. Now there's like macroeconomic stuff,
which would indicate that over time China would
lower the prices in order to account for the
tariff, but that that's not the nuts and bolts
of how the tariff works. In your experience,
did did did Chris understand that all along or
did he come to know it after those terrorists
were put in place? Or how did he understand that?
Speaker 4: Well, if he. First of all, he was very
angry about also withdrawing from TPP. But with
the tariffs, I think I mean, he was smart enough
to know what would happen. Yeah. And I think he
didn't know how long it might go on. But when
it really, really dragged on and really started
killing their business, because as he points out,
you know, it was actually farmers who negotiated
those those international agreements. Farmers had
their buyers and they had and they've been doing
this over 30 years. And basically overnight,
Trump wiped away their tried and true markets.
Speaker 1: You speak in the film to a Jewish
woman who was a Trump supporter, and then
Charlottesville happened and Trump made the
find people on both sides comments, which I
am glad to admit were slightly taken out of
context and were a little bit different than what
was the original reporting. But needless to say,
it still impacted this, this particular woman.
Can you talk about that a little bit? And I mean,
this is kind of a bigger trend wherein actual
American Jews are one of the most left wing
voting blocs that there is recently. Trump has
done this thing untruth, social, where he says,
you know, the American Jews should really shape
up here because bad things could happen. You
should be more appreciative. Talk about the Jewish
woman who you spoke to and how her views changed.
Speaker 4: I haven't talked to her in a
little bit. She's in college in Israel, but
I think that she was a Brooklyn girl and she
was the head of the Brooklyn Young Republicans,
but she'd revived the club and she was extremely
Republican and she was really dedicated. She was
very young when she got into it, but she was
blowing people away with what she could do
and what she knew. And she hung out with those
turning point people and, you know, all the young,
young Charlie Kirk type Republicans. And she
was a really, really a true believer in Trump.
Absolutely. She worked to help get him elected.
She worked in Republican campaigns in New York,
and she went to rallies. I mean, she talks about
the rallies as being like a very unhealthy drug
where everybody sort of got even more in
his thrall. The more the longer the rally,
the longer they waited line, in fact. And so she
really was all in for him. And then she heard
the Charlottesville comment and it really upset
her and disappointed her because of family who
had been killed in the Holocaust. And she was
very aware of it. And she also was very upset
by Charlottesville. And her parents actually
were refuseniks who had escaped from Russia
right around the time of perestroika. So they
finally got out. She'd heard that her mom's
dad had been a dissident, so her mom was on
the watch list just because of her dad. And
so it took them a long time to get out. And they
had told her whole life she was born in the US.
They told her whole life that, you know, this
is this is what happens when you get this kind
of extremism. This is what happens. This is what
happens. And she started to see that happening.
And then shortly after that, she saw a helsinki
and Putin and she started to get scared. And she
started to realize this guy is dangerous. He's
not what I thought he was. And I think, you know,
the very fine people on both sides comment. She
was interviewed by a local news station and said,
what would the Brooklyn Young Republicans think
of that? And she said, Well, we were all very
disappointed. And she immediately gets a call from
the head of the New York Republican Party saying,
why did you say that? And she said, I just said,
we're disappointed. Just how he felt. And he said,
well, you can't say that we're Republican and
say anything bad about Trump. And that really
that was another trigger for her with her parents
because, you know, they told her how you were,
what you said was controlled or what your
thought was control. And she just really
that really got to her. So it took her a
little bit of time. But she finally realized
she didn't care. She didn't want the sky.
Speaker 1: The you mentioned the rallies, and
I've covered so many of these Trump rallies, and
it is absolutely true that the lines to get in,
even when there aren't that many people, the lines
to get in are still crazy because of multiple
layers of security. Sometimes they're held in
really rural places that aren't actually equipped
to handle the number of people that are going.
All sorts of different reasons. Trump often runs,
you know, an hour or more late, and folks are
sometimes there all day sandy cans, blazing sun,
you know, all the horrible conditions. In my
mind, it's who would go through this in order
to hear this guy give the exact same speech
that he gives everywhere. The feedback you
got is the long wait almost reinforce the cult.
Speaker 4: Oh, yeah. There's a psychology to long
waits and it's one of the reasons sometimes
artists on purpose will go out late. Mhm. It,
it makes, it makes you believe that, you know,
you've already thrown in, you've driven all the
way there, you've gotten in line, you've gotten
your tickets, now you're waiting. Wow, this must
be really important because I'm waiting so long
and it starts to the value in your psychology
of this event goes up. So it primes you to think,
Wow, we finally got it and this is it. You know,
it's like getting into a Rolling Stones
concert, right? And Joe Walsh's wife touring
said it was like a big rock rock music event.
Speaker 1: One of the interesting things is
that once the rally actually starts, we've seen so
many times when Trump starts rambling, the crowd
will look visibly bored. Sometimes they start
filing out even during the speech. It's almost
like it's just about Trump's there and he starts
speaking and then it becomes almost irrelevant
what he says. They've been there for the event.
Speaker 4: Right. Right. I think that's a big part
of it. And also I remember reading an article,
I think it was in the post about how tailgate
parties and the people that you see at rallies
and your friends, even though they live a state
away. And so there was a whole event, part of it
like a reunion of all these like minded people who
thought Trump was like the Messiah. And that was a
big part of it, too. And one of the things, again,
Helene pointed out is that there's the same group
of people who go from rally to rally. To rally. To
rally. Yes. Yeah. You bring in locals or whatever.
But but he has a core group who come in busses and
they go to all the rallies. It's like they go
to every Grateful Dead concert, the same thing.
Speaker 1: So evangelical support for Trump,
this is something that in 2016 we saw, you know,
because there was a very big Republican primary
of which Trump only had a very small slice to
begin with. And as we all know now from the
historical record, slowly but surely, different
people were sort of fell off and the support
consolidated around Trump. The evangelical vote
was initially very much not around Trump in the
Republican primary. And when we think about why,
it seems sort of obvious Trump is a guy who was
in favor of choice for 68 years and then had to
come up with this story of why he became against
abortion, not a churchgoing guy, married, divorce,
cheating, all these different things. So it sort
of made sense that he didn't have the evangelical
support. Eventually he got most of the evangelical
support. And the way we look at it now is, well,
they weren't going to vote for Hillary. And it's
sort of like that simple. What more is there to
the eventual evangelical support for Trump?
Speaker 4: Well, how I understand it is
that he promised them he would he would make
sure to appoint these anti-abortion judges.
Speaker 1: Right.
Speaker 4: Any leaders of the
community. But the people we talked to, really,
they were influenced by their pastors. A couple in
Detroit had had pastors who would tell them,
you know, from the pulpit who to vote for and
who was evil. Hillary is evil. And then there
was another evangelical that we profiled who is
who is just a recently Liberty University graduate
that was going to be his first election. And he
said basically at Liberty University, they did
all but tell you where to make your mark. I mean,
they basically everything was pro-Trump. They had
a rally for him there. It was fliers everywhere.
It was it was the whole community being told, in
essence, to do this. And evangelical Christians
tend to be very sort of hierarchical in terms
of we listen to our pastors, they're above us.
And so pastors have a huge amount of power. And if
they're preaching from the pulpit, the vote for.
Go to hell or you know, or the woman who comes in
is going to prevent you from ever going to church
again, which is one of the things they said
that she was going to destroy the churches,
which is, of course, totally not backed
up by anything. She was actually a pretty
religious person. But I think, you know,
people hear it from a pastor. They want
to hear a simple thing. Yes. No, good, bad.
And that's what they are. And so that's how
they voted. And they still believe that.
Speaker 1: So you told us about the farmer
who over agricultural policy bailed on Trump.
You told us about the Jewish woman who over
Charlottesville bailed on Trump. What are some
of the other reasons people gave for, you know,
how did they feel? Betrayed by Trump, I guess.
Speaker 4: Well, Joe Walsh, it was definitely
Helsinki and Putin. But I actually got inspired
to make this documentary by watching Joe Walsh and
in real time change over Twitter. Yeah, because
it was estimating to watch him completely turn
around over about a year and a half. And for him,
it was Helsinki. And that was like his I mean,
as he describes, he was throwing things around
the room and he was because he really felt
that was treason. That was his belief. But the
evangelicals had different reasons. One of them
was the Liberty University grad. He had lived all
over the world with his parents, who were teachers
internationally. They had taught in South Korea,
they'd been taught in Saudi Arabia. So he had a
much more global perspective. And he really felt
that what Trump was doing to the refugees beyond
just what he was doing to them, it was more the
way he talked about them and the world where he
made them sound like a plague. And that really
upset him because having lived all over the world,
he's seen all sorts of conditions. And he believed
that his Christianity, you know, made him need to
love all those people and welcome them and try to
help them rather than demonize. So that was what
really turned him around. The other couple, the
husband, was a machinist and he had always been a
Christian for about four years. And he went to his
pastor and said, you know, I don't I'm not sure I
like this guy Trump. I don't feel very good about
him. And the pastor said, Yeah, but, you know,
we need to get we need to get the judges in and
we get these laws passed. And this is the best day
for Christianity. And he just said, okay, well,
that's what I'll do then. And he describes leaving
the voting booth, just feeling dirty, feeling
like something was wrong. He didn't know what,
but he pushed it to the back of his mind until
a year or two later, he's sitting in the break
room with one of his workers and the worker. He's
talking about Christianity and God to this worker.
And the worker is like, I just don't see why I
would want to be a Christian if you support such a
terrible human being. And it was like a lightning
bolt, hit a ball and noticed. And that, you know,
when people change or people leave cults,
whatever, you'd never know what it is. It's going
to be the first crack in that in that bubble.
Yeah, but once that crack happens, if enough
raw information gets through gradually, that can
change people's minds. And for him, for Ron, this
guy, this evangelical who was in our doc, where he
went home and he started looking in the scripture
for himself at this point, he's been a Christian
long enough and he really knows how to study. And
he goes to Bible study three times a week and
he finds all sorts of passages that describe
people like Trump being bad. Right. And he said,
no, no, no, I'm done. I'm done with this guy.
Speaker 1: The film is The Game is
up. Disillusioned Trump Voters Tell
Their Stories. We've been speaking with the
filmmaker Melissa Peltier. Super interesting
work. And I really appreciate your time today.
Speaker 4: Oh, thank you for having me. Thanks.